the question they ask us is the square
root of
c squared there are two ways to think
about this and i will show you both
they're both going to end up on the same
answer no big deal okay
here's the first way i'm going to use
this law okay
these laws they're there to help us
they're not there like oh man another
thing to memorize
they actually will make our working
easier so in particular
i'm going to look at this one right
because it's an equation you can go from
the left to the right or right to left
same thing so instead of writing this
square root sign
okay what i'm going to do is i'm going
to write
the square root of square root i'll
write the power of a half okay is that
all right
so c squared to the power of a half
these two
are the same thing okay the square root
of something
or something to the power of a half
exactly the same just a different way to
write it
but this way to write it is a little
clearer i'll show you why
when you see this this looks like this
doesn't it
can you see the brackets can you
recognize it it's the power
of a power there's one and there's the
other okay
so when you've got power of power what
do you do to the powers
you multiply them
like so two times a half that's just
one right
that's c okay so there's your answer now
i said i would show you
two ways okay the second way is to say
well
what does square root mean like what
what is the
when i say the square root of 25 what do
i mean what number times
itself is bingo let me say that again
what is the number that if you
times it by itself multiply by itself
it'll give you 25.
so i can say what's the number then when
you multiply it by itself
gives you c squared and the answer is if
you times c by itself
you'll get c squared that's what c
squared means okay
when you say like anytime something by
half times it by the half of the number
that you're trying to apply
i think you're getting confused between
multiplication and the power
so up here i mean this is to the power
of a half
right but going from here to here i'm
using a law
that's why the powers the indices
multiply by each other but like half of
what like half of c
or like no half of two that's why i
write two times
a half so that whole thing up there
that's the new power okay and then you
multiply you get one
okay now that's okay but when you move
into question three
they throw in extra numbers and it gets
a bit more confusing let me show you
three
three b b again okay
they give you sorry boston there it is
they give you this okay now the reason
why i like this approach
is because i can do it exactly the same
way and it'll still give me the right
answer
watch there's what's underneath the
square root sign
okay so what power should i write up
there which would be equivalent to the
first line
should write a half okay
now again this time look at your laws
which one of this one these laws is
going to be most relevant
look carefully at what i've got here
do i want you circled i am going to use
the one that i circled in a second
but can you see that inside the brackets
i've got two things
i've got the nine and i've got the b
squared so in fact what i want
is is as britney said the one underneath
see how i've got two things being
multiplied by each other
okay so when you've got two things
inside the brackets
all raised to a power the power grabs
onto both of them
okay so it's going to look like this 9
to the power of a half
times b squared to the power of a half
you see that
these two things are multiplied by each
other so they're both going to get the
power there they are
a half and a half okay
nine to the power of half that's the
square root of nine what's the square
root of nine
it's three because if you multiply three
by itself
you'll get nine this thing here this is
just like the question we looked at
before
it's just b okay
again just like the previous question
you can think about it the other way
what's the number that you multiply by
itself to give you 9b squared
3b times 3b
9b squared okay